debo confesar que efectivamente aunque
soy actriz y llevo ya un buen rato en
este oficio he estado en varios
escenarios inclusive este estar hablando
desde este lugar desde mí pues me pone
nerviosa y nerviosa
[Aplausos]
sin embargo al hacer este ejercicio
[Música]
y cuando me pidieron esto tuve que
recapitular ir al pasado
a pensar que había hecho el arte en mi
que había hecho el teatro en mí
y descubrí cosas
porque antes de ser actriz directora
pues también soy una mujer hija de la
guerra
sufrí abusos sexuales desde muy pequeña
estuvo un orfanato consecuencia de la
guerra
y puedo decir con propiedad que a mí el
teatro me salvó la vida
y el teatro que me salvó la vida fue el
que me hizo verme a mí con asombro
y descubrir en el primer personaje que
hice que yo tenía una mirada sumisa
recuerdo cuando hice este personaje se
llama morena
y entonces ella era tenía mucho
desparpajo
y cuando el director me dijo que yo era
sumisa tuve que ir para atrás
y descubrir y desafiar esa mirada para
poder ver con otros ojos y ponerme en la
piel de ese personaje ella es morena
también el teatro que me salvó la vida
fue el que me hizo reconciliarme con una
historia de abusos y saber que yo no era
culpable
también me hizo ponerme en los pies de
otros personajes donde ellos habían sido
los abusadores y comprendí que todo era
más complejo y entendí que el rol de
víctima y victimario a veces está en
movimiento
soy receptor de violencia que en un
momento me convierto en emisor de
violencia
y eso me lo enseñó el teatro al
descubrir miami y desde ese lugar
decidí que quería yo también compartir
esa experiencia
yo me fui hace un tiempo porque pensaba
que aquí no se podía hacer teatro y me
fui
y tuve la fortuna
de aprender cosas y quiere regresar a
este país y apostarle a que yo aquí
quería hacer teatro porque quería contar
nuestras historias con nuestra visión
del mundo
y entonces se me vino una frase de peter
brook que es un director muy conocido
que decía
si esperamos las condiciones ideales
para hacer teatro no vamos a hacer
teatro
en esa aventura que emprendía hace siete
años aquí en el salvador
conocí a un grupo de mujeres en un
taller que yo di en donde no me
imaginaba todo lo que iba a suceder y
conocí a unas mujeres que seguramente
también ustedes las han visto vendedoras
de la calle en los mercados en nuestras
casas cuidándonos limpiando nos y el
teatro tiene un poder tan fuerte y este
escenario se convierte en una lupa
que esas mujeres que llevan ya siete
años en las tablas se convirtieron en un
grupo de mujeres valientes que rara vez
levantaban su mirada y que rara vez
nosotros la volvíamos a ver
y ya llevan siete años compartiendo sus
historias recuerdo la primera vez que
nos presentamos era en un lugar que se
llamaba la luna un hermoso lugar que
existió aquí en el salvador y en ese
lugar
ella me de siempre en serio vamos a
hacer una obra de teatro de nuestras
vidas medias pero sin ni bonitas que
fueran
y yo les decía yo creo que sí yo creo
que tienen muchísimo que enseñarnos
porque ustedes representan a la mayoría
de mujeres y yo creo que podemos
aprender muchísimo de ustedes en serio
me decía
y así nos embarcamos porque les decía
miren no sé yo no tengo dinero ustedes
tampoco lo que tenemos es tiempo
probemos nada perdemos y entonces
hicimos la primera obra y fue un boom
bueno no se quisieron bajar nunca más
del escenario
y todavía recuerdo cuando uno de sus
hijos me dijo mire entonces si es actriz
yo puedo ser doctor
y me recuerdo que eso me conmovió un
montón porque ahí está la transformación
el arte es poderoso es una herramienta
poderosa siempre la hemos necesitado los
seres humanos para expresarnos desde que
nos dibujamos en una cueva
hicimos la imagen nuestra cazando porque
necesitábamos vernos y eso es el arte es
ese espejo que nos consuela también con
una canción cuando tenemos algún
despecho o emociona en aquellas
revoluciones históricas que han habido y
se han cantado esas hermosas poemas
españa
picasso hizo una pintura que se llama el
guernica
y el guernica cuenta la historia de un
pueblo que fue bombardeado ese cuadro
fue expulsado de españa durante mucho
tiempo y es un referente es un referente
del arte plástico en el mundo porque el
arte aparte de entretenimiento también
nos genera reflexión
y la reflexión es la primera fase para
poder hacer un cambio pero es necesario
también contar esas historias que muchas
veces no queremos ver porque para sanar
para sanar hay que tocar la herida
aunque duela hay que ponerle un poquito
de alcohol a boxes en nada y duele
pero luego cicatriza
en ese sentido
a parte de este grupo de mujeres
maravillosas que les he contado
conozco un grupo de amigas que formamos
otra compañía cada una más loca que la
otra
y
decidimos también que queríamos
juntarnos para hablar de ese salvador
que está ahí como estas mujeres que
están en nuestras casas y no las vemos
muchas veces no las queremos verlas
y el y dijimos vamos a contar estas
historias para poner la herida y después
sanar la pero no obviar la herida un
periodista dijo dicen que el primer paso
para la cura de un alcohólico es el
reconocimiento de su alcoholismo quizá
el primer paso para una sociedad
descompuesta sea reconocer su
descomposición
con estas amigas nos fuimos a meter a un
psiquiátrico que es el a la
penitenciaria del hospital en donde
están recluidos enfermos mentales que
han cometido delitos
cuando llegamos ahí no nos imaginamos lo
que íbamos a conocer
en serio era ese salvador que está
debajo de la alfombra y veríamos
a pacientes o reos no sé cómo llamarle
que se enfrentaban con su pasado y uno
al otro decía vos militar
vos no si era como que hasta ahí se veía
eso / ese reflejo que viese duele porque
si duele y dijimos no esto lo tenemos
que contar todavía recuerdo cuando uno
de ellos le preguntamos mire y usted
cree que hay paz en el salvador a
propósito de la conversación que tuve
eduardo ahorita usted cree que hay paz
paz con hambre no se puede
mira tan sencillo tan chiquito pero a la
vez tan fuerte hicimos una obra que se
llama los más solos
ahí están ellas en las que cada uno nos
metimos en la piel de esos personajes y
conocimos lo complejo que puede llegar a
ser el ser humano
con esta compañía además ya venimos
trabajando desde hace tiempo y queremos
muchas veces tocar esos temas incómodos
como les he venido contando y decidimos
hacer otra obra en la que estuvimos
trabajando durante tres años y tocar
esta otra herida que es la violencia
nos fuimos a patrullar con policías
nos fuimos a un barrio bravo de san
salvador que me acuerdo que íbamos con
una de ellas y me dice mira yo veo a los
policías que van bien con así con
activarla y toda donde nosotros nosotros
si pasa algo que hacemos
y no no teníamos en cuenta
y yo digo que correr
no nos pasó nada nos cuidaron muchísimo
y aprendimos muchísimo de hecho uno de
ellos ha actuado en una película que se
está haciendo y tenemos una relación
estrecha y nos metimos y vamos caminando
detrás de ellos veíamos lo que
significaba ir con policías en este país
en ese barrio y comprendimos más cosas
porque muchas veces son los malos esos
buenos y cómo va cambiando ese ese
concepto y recuerdo todavía uno de ellos
que además tenía este gesto me acuerdo
perfectamente de él y dice mire me dijo
usted que ve aquí
qué piensa de esto me dijo
mire yo le dije la verdad que yo lo que
veo es extrema pobreza y sabía que iba a
decir eso sabe que veo yo me dijo
extrema delincuencia
es lógico eses observadores es la mirada
que tiene y es necesaria yo no digo que
no pero también es necesario que hayan
otras miradas porque no puede ser sólo
la represión es necesario
que hay otro tipo de intervención
también en esos barrios y no solo el
pinchazo
y así fuimos descubriendo cosas y llegó
el día hicimos un preestreno
y la presentamos para policías y esta es
una de las primeras escenas en donde se
ven a los policías
golpeando muchachos y todo fuerte en
esta escena
estaba muy nerviosa eran 60 policías dos
comunidades de jóvenes
un chico que está saliendo de estas
bandas que está trabajando con otros
jóvenes en el mismo público casi que
nuestros personajes estaban ahí
nerviosa
y si me entienden el mensaje si quieren
que los estamos atacando y hicimos la
obra se sentía sobre todo en esta escena
una tensión yo siento al público se
siente y entonces termina la obra el
oscuro se enciende la paula y yo nos
agarramos la mano hicimos bueno pues a
ver qué pasa se enciende la luz y el
primero que se puso de pie fue un
policía y empezaron tú
y los jóvenes yo creo que se liberaron
porque todos estaban a ver qué va a
pasar hicieron y se rompió ese silencio
porque no se puede hablar de esos temas
ver oír y callar y de pronto verlo y
hablarlo es como a como librar una olla
de presión que está ahí contenida y eso
como para que no estalle la olla de
frijoles en el techo
entonces por eso es que el arte tiene un
poder maravilloso porque nos permite
hablar del dolor de la violencia del
amor a través de la belleza porque la
belleza hace que eso se pueda
y sentir no podemos olvidar que nuestro
arte también busca la forma pero cuando
según el contenido y el discurso es
poderoso y es una herramienta poderosa
de transformación social y de educación
que muchas veces no se tiene en cuenta y
se cree que la educación es un profesor
dictando plana esta obra ya lo hemos
presentado pues alrededor para como 250
policías y hemos tenido conversatorios
muy sinceros en los que uno de ellos
también me decía mire no le voy a negar
que verse ahí uno mismo es chocante no
lo voy a negar menos
pero pues si no se puede seguir tapando
el sol con un dedo y esto es la realidad
y cuando ya se acepta y cuando ya se
dice si pasa si ya se genera un cambio
no lo había visto de esta manera no
había puesto en el pie del otro y por
eso considero esta fuerza que tiene el
arte y reivindicó el teatro en estos
tiempos en donde la comunicación muchas
veces se va cada vez con máquinas con
imágenes con las redes sociales y
hablamos y nos olvidamos a veces del
contacto y de lo importante del contacto
humano y por eso celebra el teatro
porque para que suceda tienen que estar
ustedes y tenemos que estar nosotros
aquí y eso es maravilloso porque hay
comunidad y hay un encuentro humano
yo quería pedirles algo
quisiera
que por un momentito los que quieran una
cosa chiquita cerrar los ojos un
momentito chiquitito
y piensen la primera vez que tuvieron un
contacto con alguna disciplina artística
con alguna canción que les consoló una
película una novela
una imagen en un cuadro que me conmovió
imagínense por estos segundos sin eso si
de pronto ya no existe nada de eso no
puedo ver una película una novela leer
un cuento
solo son no somos robots
ahora despido a bien voy a poner a la
izquierda que vuelvan a ver a su
izquierda
y vean a la persona que tienen a la par
como es como son sus manos como va
vestida
y que haya contacto
estaba ahí y quizás no me había fijado
quizás es un personaje
[Risas]
jaja
es en el teatro que yo hago en el que yo
creo
como les dije al principio
mi madre participó en un conflicto
terrible que hubo aquí en el salvador
pero si me enseñó algo
me dijo que había que hacer algo por los
demás y que ya lo había hecho de esa
manera porque es la que había encontrado
yo no creo en la guerra ni en las armas
pero sí creo en hacer algo y encontré
que el teatro podría ser mi herramienta
pienso y les invito a que cada quien
desde su trinchera pueda hacer algo y
dejar una huella como han dicho varias
personas hoy en esta mañana en este
mundo
y sentir que puedo incidir en algo y no
solo pasar por pasar
yo vivo de eso de contar cuentos porque
creo que es mejor saber a no saber y
sigo defendiendo que el arte es una
herramienta poderosa de transformación y
acción social muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]